[Music]
5 24 into Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy how about a friendly
Highway 93 note from a Northerly
neighbor
Susan from Caliente writes greetings to
all who travel the rural highways of
Southern Nevada you may think you're in
the middle of nowhere along the
Brannigan Reservoir but this is our main
street please be patient and courteous
when driving to our lovely very large
community speeding and tailgating are
dangerous Highway 93 is a narrow winding
road with little shoulder allowance and
that's mostly gravel slow down enjoy the
ride you'll get to the Wide Open Spaces
once you've passed our area and if we
see you driving recklessly we might pass
right on by if you get stranded we
really are in the middle of nowhere when
it comes to roadside services
there aren't any
most folks in the area recognize friends
and Neighbors when we see them on the
road and will stop to help them it's
probably one of the reasons they like
living up here
Susan thank you for riding in thanks for
the refresher course on what most of
Nevada is really all about buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone now you can join the driving you
crazy conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com